so I'm here at the York property
investors Network and it's absolutely
beautiful here just that the pleasure of
speaking in front of an excited
successful group of investors and I just
wanted to give a real showery to
networking I think I'm a strong believer
that to invest in property you need
three things and most people say that
the most important thing you need is
money
followed by knowledge and then a good
network is also useful as well you know
I completely disagree with that I think
the most important thing to be a
successful property investor is having a
good Network followed by knowledge and
then finally money I mean money is not
that important it's important but you
don't it's not important that you have
it to start with I started with nothing
pretty much and over the space of a few
years but up a million-pound property
portfolio because of who I knew and the
systems that I was taught not because of
what I had in the bank so I hope that's
encouraged so you have a wonderful day
we'll do whatever you do wherever you
are I've got if you've not read my this
book by the way do the possible watch
God do the impossible is my first book
it's also an Amazon bestseller so I
encourage checking that out it's all
about faith business philosophy success
so yeah god bless your speech you soon